c'est une première dans le département
et la date du lundi 8 mars journée
internationale des droits des femmes n'a
pas été choisie au hasard
la ville de ben et la préfecture des
yvelines ont signé ce matin un contrat
de mobilisation et de coordination
locale contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles
c'est vraiment une action importante sur
le territoire de la commune et c'était
normal qu'en cette journée du 8 mars
l'état souligne par la signature de
cette convention la qualité de cet
engagement
elle a souhaité faire de cette lutte
résolue contre les violences faites aux
femmes un marqueur de son action
municipale objectifs de cette convention
assurer la mobilisation des services
municipaux des associations et des
services de l'état sur le territoire de
bennes pour garantir une protection
efficace contre les violences sexistes
et sexuelles
ce qui est important pour nous c'est la
suite de tout un engagement qui dure
depuis plusieurs années déjà
le but est aidé à porter et de dire
voilà une commune s'engage essayé toutes
les communes et je porterai ce discours
ailleurs de s'engager justement et plus
on amplifiera le mouvement plus on aura
de résultats et c'est le but que je me
suis assignées en tant que particulier
avant mais aussi maintenant en tant que
maire cette convention tout comme les
bons taxi qui transportent les victimes
en milieu rural doivent contribuer à la
diminution des faits de violences
sexistes et sexuelles ou comme le maire
de bègles espère les faire disparaître